let's begin with mega Markel because she
actually just hosted her first palace
party yeah making it Palace official
agency I love that and I love that Megan
brought her mama it's the first time
that we have seen Doria in the UK since
the wedding and they seem to have such a
nice adamant daughter relationship but
alright let's be real as much as we'd
love seeing them together everybody was
how should I put it expecting to see
something would go
working on this project for the past
nine months has been a tremendous labor
of love and with those words nine months
and labor of love we can't help but
think make it appears fully aware of the
pregnancy rumors that popped up when she
wore this blue dress and that she's
poking fun at the Twittersphere was a
very sly sense of humor
it was the duchess of sussex his first
official charity engagement to launch a
cookbook that she's been heavily
involved with she stood up she delivered
a smallest three-minute speech and her
mother was there to support her great
surprise for everyone who clearly very
important bacon that look right there on
Prince Harry's face is proof the
honeymoon phase is so not over and how
about this adorable moment caption quote
when you just have to flatten down the
wife's hair on a windy day royal insight
is sustaining that Megan and Harry are
quite eager to start a family my sources
are saying that there isn't a pregnancy
just yet but Harry is protective of his
new wife he's completely besotted and
nothing would make him happier than if
they were starting a family I mean it
truly took a village to see this through
while they may have babies on the brain
the royal couple is putting charity
first in three and a half weeks they
begin their first royal tour in
Australia there will be a lot of
attention on them as a couple the
chemistry between them and of course I'm
sure people do watching for a baby bump
as well
[Music]